this is fascinating last week when Ron
DeSantis responded to Trump's attack on
him by saying I don't spend my time
attacking other Republicans DeSantis
took the high road as we discussed I
told you this isn't going to work for
DeSantis and I've expressed concerns
previously that in a national campaign
DeSantis who lacks all Charisma I mean
just completely uncharismatic I don't
know how DeSantis faces off against
Trump and the nicknames and the attacks
in a national campaign
I'm not the only one saying this this is
really interesting there's a New York
Times article published uh two days ago
called desantis's challenge when and how
to counter-attack Trump the article is
by Michael Bender and Maggie Haberman
and in this article they actually
addressed this issue
he's trying to take the high road but
that is not likely to work and there's a
paragraph that says some deep pocketed
Republican donors have privately
expressed concern about how DeSantis
will perform when forced to directly
engage with an opponent as combative
and unbothered by traditional rules of
decorum as Mr Trump Liam Donovan a
Republican strategist said no Republican
has ever emerged from an exchange with
Donald Trump looking stronger so the
natural tendency is to deflect attacks
and avoid confrontation that's easy to
do maybe wise when Trump's barbs are
confined to truth social the question is
what happens when DeSantis finds himself
on a debate stage opposite Trump and
Republicans vote Republican voters want
to see whether they are getting what
they were promised I think this article
is exactly right and I think that the
Republicans who are bringing this up are
a hundred percent justified in being
concerned with this and the article
mentions all of these uh you know
different
um attacks that Trump launched against
challengers in 2016 insinuating that Ted
Cruz's father was linked to the
assassination of John F Kennedy uh
calling Ben Carson pathological
making fun of the appearance of Ted
Cruz's wife and of Rand Paul and so on
and so forth this is exactly right and
so while I believe that at least in
theory right now Ron DeSantis is well
positioned for a run against Trump if he
announces and if he takes the campaign
seriously and he'll he has a shot
there's no doubt but if they emerge as
the Front Runners Trump and DeSantis and
if they end up on stage against each
other and DeSantis does this High Road
stuff while Trump brutally attacks
DeSantis and he will it doesn't look
good for DeSantis I don't actually
believe that Republican voters are going
to be swayed by a guy who takes the high
road I think they want to see who here
brings the sort of like you know what
they what they wrongly believe to be
Alpha energy and whatever else and uh I
don't think the Santa's taking the high
road will work and DeSantis does need to
figure out how do I attack Trump when do
I attack Trump or the chance that he has
at this thing is going to very quickly
evaporate let me know your thoughts what
should desantis's approach be
um and we will certainly have time to
discuss this further Trump has started
to go after DeSantis in casual
conversations they say describing him as
all sorts of different strange things
based on his physical appearance so
Trump seems to be winding it up and even
though Trump says he's not thinking
about it all of the indications are that
he is Trump's going to be ready this is
you know Trump's not going to be ready
with that health care plan that we were
going to get in August of 2020. I'm not
holding my breath waiting for that
health care plan Trump is going to be
ready for how to attack Ron DeSantis and
DeSantis has to figure out what to do